[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci nous trouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip nous
accueillons aujourd'hui une personnalité
yvelinoise une perte humaine n'est que
l'on connaît car elle déjà venue des
juste un an
c'est christine de mazières alors
christine de mazières bonjour merci
d'être à nouveau présente sur notre
plateau il ya juste un an vous veniez
nous présenter un premier roman trois
jours à berlin qui se passait donc en 89
on peut en dire juste deux trois mots de
l'histoire oui c'était sur l'histoire de
la chute du mur de berlin
d'accord ou deux trois mots vides est
parfaite je suis la petite fille
exactement
et aujourd'hui vous sortez un nouveau
roman toujours dans la même maison
d'édition sabine wespiser qui s'intitule
la route des balkans
voilà alors un autre sujet j'ai oublié
de dire que a pas des trotteurs vous
êtes aussi magistrate mais ça vaut comme
on vous connaît on sait ça c'est dit
voilà alors ce nouveau roman qui est
comme le premier assez à des cours très
dense très très très riche
comment l'idée vous en est elle venue
j'ai été très frappée est bouleversée
par un incident qui est arrivé en 2015
on a retrouvé sur les routes de entre la
hongrie et la et l'autriche
un camion frigorifique rempli de
réfugiés est touché et c'était vraiment
le moment où de par là
les guerres en syrie en irak que des
milliers des dizaines de milliers de
réfugiés prenez la route des balkans
chercher la survie du groupe
et cet événement m'a bouleversée je
trouve que c'est une vraiment la
tragédie de notre temps c'est ces flux
de réfugiés qui cherchent asile et voilà
j'avais envie de me mettre dans la peau
de ces de ces personnes est également de
ceux en europe de nous mais voilà parmi
les oiseaux dans la dans la peau de
plusieurs personnages bédié parce que
comme vous le premier moment vous êtes
on peut dire un roman choral
on a la vie de plusieurs personnages qui
se retrouvent ou pas d'ailleurs mon sens
ils ont tous quelque part un lien vous
pouvez nous citer quelques personnages
déjà les principaux jeux pas mme asma je
pensais en italie malaisie réalisé deux
personnages principaux qui sont une
jeune syrienne qui s'appelle asma avec
sa soeur qui sont partis précipitamment
de syrie suite à quoi
suite à la fois alors à leur arrestation
et elles ont été maltraitées
pendant leur reprise au mans ils doivent
partir elles ont pas le choix
et puis un autre personnage qui
s'appelle tamim qui était un jeune
afghan un afghan qui lui étant sur la
route depuis trois ans en langue il est
parti très trash il est alors les deux
ont 17 ans donc c'est à dire que tamim
est parti à l'âge de 14 ans là où c'est
contraint et forcé pour sauver sa vie il
a quitté sa mère et ses soeurs sont son
père et ses frères aînés ont déjà été
tuées et parce qu'une tribu les hasards
a qui sont absolument persécuté par par
bateau notamment les talibans et donc
lui il a déjà un chemin absolument
terrifiant de des montagnes de
l'afghanistan jusque jusqu'aux portes de
l'europe et ces destins vont croiser
également d
en fait les personnes qui sont les
passeurs oui aussi un des personnages
qui est un passeur alors à bâle ii qui
de tallinn de radomir qui étaient 1,2
milliard et aimer la part d'autres
causes justes lumière oui il y les
cellules conducteur du camion c'est lui
le conduire à la retraite comme vous
dites il habite à l'homme ce sombre le
plus pauvre d'europe apparemment et le
prouver à samba lui-même à a été
exploité en allant travailler en saxe
pour gagner un tout petit peu de sou ils
essaient de monter son propre café et
finalement ça marche pas parce qu'alors
on dépose donc on n'a pas d'argent pour
aller boire un café donc ils se
retrouvent à nouveau après avoir lutté à
nouveau dans la misère et finalement il
va faire la misère même plus que le même
malheur des autres
en acceptant ce jeu dévoile trop là ou
par non mais il est lui-même
effectivement c'est intéressant ce qui
est ce qui est bien dans la littérature
c'est que on ne porte pas de jugement on
raconte des histoires là vous voyez bien
ce jeune bulgare est lui-même effective
il vient de la région la plus pauvre
d'europe est lui-même exploiter sans
savoir vraiment ce qu'il fait il va le
réaliser
évidemment mais mais c'est intéressant
aussi de montrer son parcours et puis il
ya aussi une famille allemande
alors voilà au bout du chemin est-ce que
excusez moi on n'a pas dit vous êtes
franco allemands vont trouver maman et
allemandes a tout à fait un pays que
vous connaissez évidemment très bien
vous y avez souvent vous avez un lien
très fort nous qu'on voit déjà dans nos
trois jours à berlin
là ça se retrouve ici ces allemands sont
bas tout ce sont 16 10 plus mais sont
plutôt à l'ouest ou à l'est
enfin ex la famille de vous parler à ma
famille dans la mine en livre dans la
foule était plutôt l ouest et l ouest
mais elle vient de l'est
voilà sens que la un grès la grand mère
elle garde de 75 ans en fait est une
elle même ou une réfugiée de la prusse
orientale c'est à dire qu'une experts
quelle ligne gras d'aujourd'hui vont en
russie
et dont j'avais envie de mettre en
perspective le passé
de réfugiés de beaucoup d'européens
nationalement d'allemands puisqu'il 13
millions d'allemands qui ont été
finalement 45 refoulé des des provinces
de l'est plus ou polonaises aujourd'hui
vers l'allemagne et qui peut expliquer
aussi une partie des réactions très
ouverte et très accueillante d'accord
voilà dans ce passé il y a il y à cette
connaissance dresse des visites et
articles du fait qu'on peut voilà partir
sur les routes pour pour sauver sa vie
et qu on est bien content d'être
accueillis à un moment donné voilà donc
en fait d'ailleurs enfin je reviens
souvent premier mais voilà vous disiez
j'ai crié que les allemands de l'est
étaient des migrants dans leur tête ou
dans leurs rêves où je les ai inventées
cette phase enfin cette espèce de dents
vie de quitter son pays dans lequel on
n'est pas heureux et d'aller ailleurs
non je vois ce qu'il avançait un bazooka
chemin mais bon l'idée des slas et
partage cette notion il se met plus
facilement peut-être que d'autres
européens à la place de ces migrants
points c'est à dire que en plus la
catastrophe est encore très présent tout
en la conscience des allemands ou des
catastrophes qu'ils ont eux même initié
et qui a déclenché des mis des millions
de morts et de et de destins déplacer
effectivement donc c'est une question
très sensible
de plus il y a aussi comme vous disiez
il ya l'allemagne l'allemagne de l'ouest
et l'allemagne de l'est
il reste trente ans après la chute du
mur encore des distinctions dans dans le
vécu dans les mentalités et donc dans ce
roman je montre aussi des personnages à
l'est que c'est vrai que là encore sans
porter de jugement mais pour essayer
d'expliquer inquirer les différentes
nuances et eu des réactions différentes
et ça permet de comprendre un peu mieux
les comportements des personnes
voilà tout à fait parce que
comment dire déjà cette fameuse aile
gare la dame de 75 ans qui est donc
d'origine de l'est ou croit résolue elle
est allemande elle women in d'origine
par sa mère comme expert voilà de très
loin mais oui c'est une des recrues en
parle donc finul au total
bref sa mère a été tuée et violée par
l'armée rouge
quand elle avait 5 enfin tout ça fait qu
finalement comme en histoire des
migrants d'aujourd'hui alors ce livre il
se passe entre 2012 et 2015
c'est ça c'est essentiellement quand
même quinze jours en 2015 ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui un peu la crise des
réfugiés
entre la fin du mois d'août et le début
du mois de septembre il y a eu un afflux
immense de réfugiés et plusieurs
catastrophes donc femme celle de ce
camion mais aussi le petit à ilan petit
garçon de 3 ans qui a été retrouvé on a
vu les taux sur la plage il ya eu
beaucoup de moments qui ont bouleversé
très concentré sur un laps de temps et
puis peu après ces deux ces deux moments
très bouleversant qui ont et qui ont
fait d'eux les images en fait on s'est
mis tout le monde je suis il y a eu ce
qu'on a appelé à tort l'ouverture des
frontières par l'allemagne
et ça m'intéressait de raconter un peu
ce moment historique
un peu comme dans trois jours à berlin
le l'ouverture delà du mur qui était
finalement décidé par personne
acte manqué là en réalité il n'y a pas
d'ouverture hume du mur vingt dieux de
la frontière puisque les frontières
étaient ouvertes il ya simplement une
décision de ne pas les fermer et une
aide concrète de la part de l'allemagne
et une un accueil un analogue
essentiellement de la population
d'ailleurs wimbée secours alertés il
vient les gens viennent aider de même
l'immense majorité de la population
allemande et autrichienne en
l'occurrence parce que là le pas sera le
triste et je voulais un petit peu
raconté la manière dont ça s'est passé
est pas maintenant ce mythe qui
d'ailleurs a été forgé entre deux
légendes qui a été forgée sur
l'ouverture des frontières
le grand remplacement est à des fins
politiques et donc il me semblait
intéressant en arrière fond de toutes
ces histoires de destins humains
dramatique ou mais il ya aussi beaucoup
d'espoirs derrière les l'art de raconter
au fond le déroulé de ces quinze jours
incroyables qui ont conduit à l'accueil
on a vu les images là aussi sur les
quais de gare de de plein de gens qui
venaient avec des cadeaux des des
boissons pour accueillir ces migrants
s'est réfugié on n'en croyaient pas
leurs yeux enfin qui était qui était
tout à fait saisi mais ça n'a pas duré
et là encore je pense le comme dans
trois jours à berlin ce sont deux
moments de fraternité et finalement de
89 2015
à 26 ans de dca mais des moments de
fraternité qui durent pas forcément un
peu éphémère et dans ce cas là tout
s'est vraiment refermé après coup louis
et des nouveaux murs se sont créés
notamment mur construit à la hongrie et
d'autres encore bien d'autres encore
aujourd'hui tout s'est un peu refaire
mais c'est un peu trop beau pour durer
deux ans 2020 on voit on voit des images
en grèce partout
dans la méditerranée
de réfugiés qui perdent la vie en
voulant venir vers l'europe
en voulant sauver leur vie en fait bien
sûr bon en attendant c'est un beau
moment que vous nous racontez finalement
avec ce moment de grâce et de fraternité
comme vous dites qui dure très peu mais
au moins il enrhumé d'exister et c'est
et c'est très très intéressant justement
votre façon de montrer des choses un peu
d'en haut et de comment disais tout à
l'heure de comprendre un peu les
comportements de chacun et les réactions
alors merci beaucoup d'être venu sur ce
plateau est ce que je vous ai déjà posé
la question la dernière fois vous
m'aviez dit je ne sais pas que vous avez
un procès un livre déjà en projet ce que
c'est une trilogie possible ou
impossible j'ai effectivement je pense
que j'écris dès que je peux oui c'est
rattraper le oui oui danser c'est vrai
que c'est pour moi je dirais
vraiment l'essentiel de ma vie le coeur
de ma vie honda est vital même si
jusqu'à présent je n'ai pas eu beaucoup
de temps pour huit golfeurs
rappelle-t-on et effectivement j'ai un
autre livre en préparation bon moi je
n'ai alors aujourd'hui fois à l'année
prochaine 11 est bas au bts et bac
commence en attendant merci christine de
mazières merci beaucoup mais je
recommande à tout le monde ce très beau
roman qui est clair voilà à bientôt
merci merci à tous
[Musique]